voilà plusieurs mois que le monde est
plongé dans la crise du coronavirus sans
que personne n'ait pu anticiper ce
phénomène sans précédent personne ou
presque car si ces derniers temps les
voyants et autres médiums ont été
beaucoup moqué pour ne pas avoir vu
venir ce qui a été la pire crise
sanitaire
une voyante avait quant à elle prédit
cette épidémie mondiale dans un livre
publié en 2008 sylvain braun un ticket
vers 2020 une sévère maladie de type
pneumonie se répandre à travers le globe
attaquant les poumons et les branches et
résistant à tous les traitements connus
avant d'ajouter fait sans doute plus
déroutant que la maladie en elle-même
elle disparaîtra aussi rapidement
qu'elle est arrivée et frappera à
nouveau dix ans plus tard avant de
totalement disparaître une voyante qui
n'est pas n'importe qui sylvia brown est
une figure médiatique aux états unis et
dionne des stars elle est aussi à
l'origine de nombreuses polémiques et
dérapages comme lorsqu'elle avait
annoncé en 2004 à la télé à une maman
que sa fille disparue était décédée
alors qu'elle a été retrouvé neuf ans
plus tard vivante des dérapages en série
qui ne l'auront pas empêché cette
fois-ci de viser juste
l'extrait de son livre a été relayée sur
les réseaux sociaux par kim kardashian
un coup de pub gigantesque qui a relancé
massivement les ventes en ligne
néanmoins s'il vient ne pourra pas
beaucoup profité des recettes de ses
ventes puisqu'il est morte en 2013
alors selon vous cette prédiction très
précise et elle dure un coup de chance
ou un véritable don
alors c'est la coupe du monde des débats
cette réduction très précise et elle une
chance à un hasard ou un don rené
malleville toi tu penses que c'est un
hasard ou un nom déjà là bas c'est un
con je ne crois pas elle fait pas mouche
aller les voir une seule fois je suis
allé et make you and i know you need u
roy lé bonnardel est maintenant au
bailleur je suis allé à bas prix 40
euros et la convertir dans votre famille
il ya un mec qui tape telles injures
non non et mille ha non alors il votre
père il s'appelle jeanne et or une colle
fini m a pris 40 oger limited les
premiers les derniers je ne crois
absolument pas à ce genre de les femmes
d'horizons à l'égard de l'harmonie et de
trouvailles comme une fois c'est moi
mais m e tour du droit et bien voilà
c'est se gaver sur la bêtise humaine
sophie cottes vous vous y croyez à soir
parce que c'est complètement fou
enseignants qui avaient prédit quand
même qu'en 2020 il y aurait une maladie
grave de type no money qui rêve qui se
répand dans le monde antiste en 2008 ans
elle est assez extraordinaire enfin elle
était assez extraordinaire sida brand
elle a travaillé notamment avec le
vieillard et 5 secrets etc
il travaille beaucoup d'ailleurs les
services secrets l'événement génère un
gène rôles à ceillac avec des
mentalistes avec des médiums très c'est
connu c'est de notoriété publique et
surtout tous les hommes politiques
avaient leurs voyants ou leur astrologue
on sait très bien que par exemple en
soit différent ne prenez aucune décision
sans lisa baissier on avait un exemple
assez assez incroyable charles de gaulle
on pense être quelqu'un d'assez
rationnelle en fait été très branché sur
les réseaux tourisme et il avait
justement un type aussi qui voyait tout
le temps qui s'appelait maurice basset
et qu'ils consultaient mais non-stop
pour avoir justement savoir quelle
décision politique et devait prendre et
c'est donc effectivement il ya des gens
moi je pense qu'ils ont un don une
espèce d'acuité bien plus fine que
certaines autres personnes et c'est le
prouver enfin je veux dire c'est un
moment donné voilà ces grands
entrepreneurs aussi qui prennent les
décisions
grâce aux astronomes grâce au médium
c'est pas par hasard une mauvaise rené
l'oni la police les
le but biya est toujours qu'il y trouve
beaucoup plus avec les balances qu'avec
les voyages
même de gaulle à moi je suis pas un
grand admirateur de gaulle mais je
reconnais quand même sa stature ben ils
allaient voir une voyante mais c'est pas
parce que des sommes dues certaine
notoriété certaine notoriété vont devoir
des voyages qu'il faut y croire que
sinon il ya 66 millions de procès qui va
voir les voyages de demain est ce qu
elle veut dit ne le fais je me dis je
devienne visionnaire on va rentrer et on
va rappeler l'info les chéris si vous
nous rejoignez on va devoir rappeler
l'info c'est que dans un livre ça fait
énormément parler ce weekend end of day
il a été créé en 2008 par une médium qui
s'appelle sylvain parent 1 que dans 12
ans il y aurait donc une grave maladie
dans le monde entier de type no money
vers 2020 a pour croire pour l'instant
qui vous a convaincu très vite sophie
parce qu'on va pas ça ne va qu'à three
en amènera laisse jamais le livre de
ducati parle cyril elle décrit mais
mot-à-mot mot-à-mot ce qui va se sortait
ce qui se passe en ce moment en 2000 par
c'est à dire que véritablement elle
parle d'un virus qui va toucher les
bronches et les poumons passer d'une
précision extraordinaire donc rené
effectivement il ya des charlatans dans
toutes les professions
mais il ya certaines personnes qui ont
un don voilà pour ce genre et les choses
et rené aussi ont été avérés donc il
faut entendre ça aussi après je ne
comprenais pas mais pas grise regarde y
avait une voix y avait redonné voler ses
taux mais ce que je sais c'est que des
messieurs chéri ce que ce samedi en
début d'émission
je sais pas ce qu'est quitte à raconter
ça que 110 ans le 1er déc top cinéma le
4 mai et ça c'est une connerie ça ça
très carrée sur twitter la voilà cela
c'est une colline je viens d'écouter les
informations
si sa mort les dernières 24 heures le
plus grand nombre de morts depuis le
confinement
mais oui je te le dis donc ça c'est des
conneries mental alors c'est un truc est
sorti sur une carte
on a dit et cela si ça se passe le
message vous irez et je ne pas laisser
moins de tous les avions à partir du 16
mai on va commencer peut-être ça ça
m'importe
après les voyants palais royal et
friches qui travaillent en foot dans le
milieu lausanne
moment visiter deux que nous passons
dans lequel on est je m'en fous que la
voyais alto y avait dit elle a dit il y
aura sa n'ont pas d'amis ici là nous on
s'en fout on sent qu'il a acceptée voire
à m'échauffer je voudrais qu'on voit les
résultats s'il taupe et sophie merci
déchets verts si chéri merci sophy les
résultats s'il vous plaît sur twitter
après on va passer au deuxième débat sur
matt pokora victime de son d'humour matt
pokora s'il vous plaît ce qu'on peut
avoir les résultats qui vous a plus
qu'on a pu cerner à 56% face à sophie
44% donc rené voilà les gens n'y croient
pas à cette histoire de voyante voilà
hasard à 71 % dont à 29 % d'eau